[Musique]
et là 42 ans et exerce le plus vieux
métier du monde rubis parle sans
complexe de son rôle de dominatrice
c'est ici qu'elle reçoit ses clients
dans une maison de prostitution dans un
quartier bien ordinaire de Berlin malgré
cette ouverture il reste des tabous
comme le choix des mots qu'on emploie
dit-elle choisissent ce travail elle
rejette l'étiquette de victime si les
mots ont autant d'importance c'est que
le débat sur la prostitution en
Allemagne n'est pas clos même si
l'industrie et légale depuis plusieurs
années ici et selon Ruby le lobby qui
s'oppose au travail du sexe parle de
plus en plus fort
[Musique]
pour Rogna être une prostituée n'est pas
une carrière et l'expression
travailleuse du sexe représente mal la
réalité elle préfère le terme prostituée
elle insiste aussi sur le choix des mots
de la prostitution pour y être resté
pendant 10 ans elle se rendait chez des
clients ou les rencontrer dans des
chambres d'hôtel et pendant une courbe
période et la travailler dans des
maisons closes elle insiste personne ne
l'a forcé à entrer dans le monde de la
prostitution
mais aujourd'hui il réalise que son
enfance marqué par la violence l'avait
rendu vulnérable peeling
elle se demande à quel point les jeunes
filles se prostituent de leur plein gré
et ajoute que plusieurs ne s'attendent
pas aux côtés sombres de la prostitution
puisqu'elle est légale
[Musique]
maintenant pour l'instauration du modèle
nordique celui qui a adopté le Canada un
système qui pénalise les clients mais
pas les prostituées
elle veut changer les règles qui ont à
son avis créer un important marché et on
va lui à l'Allemagne la réputation de
bordel de l'Europe
[Musique]
à deux pas d’une des plus grandes places
financières d'Europe la prostitution se
déroule au vu et au-dessus de tous
bienvenue dans le quartier rouge de
Francfort
[Musique]
du modèle nordique selon elle une
génération d'Allemands agrandi dans un
pays où la prostitution et légale et où
10 euros peuvent autant servir à acheter
un burger calé dans une maison close
quelle est la taille réelle de cette
industrie 20 ans après que le Parlement
est adopté une loi encadrant de façon
très générale la prostitution difficile
de le savoir
selon elle des mégas maison de
prostitution ont poussé un peu partout
il y a beaucoup de bordel il y a aussi
beaucoup de place où il y a de la de la
prostitution individuelle je crois que
c'est mieux que il y a de place légale
ou la police sache que il y a de la
prospection qu'on peut contrôler même
cette chercheuse doit composer avec des
données très imprécises au niveau de
logique ça fait sens que des personnes
qui vivent dans un pays où il ce n'est
pas légal du vendredi sexe qu'il vienne
ici parce que il y a quand même des
conditions générales meilleures
l'Allemagne est-elle vraiment devenue le
bordel de l'Europe peut-être il est
correcte de dire que l'Allemagne le
bordel d'Europe c'est parce que il n'y a
pas ce n'est pas légal dans notre pays à
la loi de 2002 c'est ajouter celle de
2017 depuis les prostituées doivent
déclarer leur activité et le condom est
obligatoire des changements qui ne règle
pas le débat ces femmes qui connaissent
le milieu veulent encore être entendus
les travailleuses du sexe doivent être
traités comme tout le monde plaide rubis
j'ai l'espoir d'ironia que de plus en
plus de gens réalisent que la
prostitution créée de nombreuses
victimes elle se préoccupe toute des
femmes sans s'entendre sur le meilleur
modèle à adopter pour qu'elle soit
pleinement respectées les débats
entourant le plus vieux métier du monde
risque de se poursuivre longtemps